control is the issue
always and everywhere and we've got this
scene
so controlled that you know we're on the
brink of armageddon
behind control how can it be
very very carefully deconstructed
well i think the first thing is we have
to open
a pipeline to the logos
we have to reach the goddess mind behind
nature and this means following the
classical prescriptions of shamanism
it's true what they say what the shamans
say
is truer than anything we can say about
them in other words it's not that
they're putting it through a language
filter
or that they're epistemologically naive
or some horseshit like that that's not
it's you
who are epistemologically naive and
me we have no idea
what is possible in nature
in positions of courage and high
intoxication
so the uh i see the whole
20th century as a very you know
it's like trying to turn a battleship
with an oar
it's very very slow going but with freud
and young we get the discovery of the
unconscious
i mean they discover it through a
spyglass at 900 yards but they do
announce that it's out there and then
you know through surrealism abstract
expressionism
psychedelic drugs we are now exploring
this domain we
the analogous cultural crisis is
the uh late 15th century
the 1490s printing was invented in mainz
in 1440 by 1492
the new world had been discovered
it's 1490. we need to go
somewhere we don't know quite where but
you can almost taste it what it is
is that we i think are getting set
to take flight into what has always
been our destiny we're
special we are not
outside the plan but we're
in a loop of the plan that the rest of
organic nature
is not participating in we are the hands
of the planetary mind and the
technologies that we have assembled
are for the purposes of the planetary
mind
surely it must sense the finite nature
of the life of the planet and the star
itself we are a kind of strategy
for moving energy around someone once
said
animals are a strategy invented by
plants for moving seeds around
well i think human beings are a strategy
invented by nature for catalyzing
natural process clearly
the whole planet is being sped up
we are preparing to depart
for a dimension which
can only be called the imagination
this is what culture is
8 000 years ago when we began to crowd
into cities
and build walls and define everything
into grids and mandalas
that was the beginning of the
excrescence
of mental space that's what we're living
in these are all ideas
this was just unorganized matter put
through
the mills and presses of design
to create a world that reflects
the world that is living on the other
side of our foreheads
the world of our imagination but it has
always operated
against the background of the laws of
physics
you know the strength of materials the
laws of gravity
you just can't build bridges with spans
more than
x or skyscrapers taller than y
but in the imagination wishes are horses
beggars ride and this is the cultural
dimension
that we have a potential
to create i don't think that there's a
way to manage this thing
back down into the
equilibrial pastoralism of 20 000 years
ago
we burned those bridges it's a real
crisis we will not recognize
our grandchildren
[Music]
you